what a l what a l what a l what an
[Music]
absolute H what a lad well today I'm
lucky enough to be joined by a man many
didn't think I'd be able to get on here
but here I am very proud to have one of
the greats on he's someone who's taken a
very different Pathway to the top than
most no New Zealand age groups he's gone
from playing Country Club ragby to
becoming one of the best tight head
props in the world during his time with
canb the Crusaders and the or
he's also someone who's always says it
how it is and he's of course an absolute
lad it is the great Joe Moody welcome
mate thanks very much for having me on
man uh maybe you should have done your
homework a little bit better before you
got me on cuz I'm actually a loose head
prop oh no Piggy's going to be filthy
you can play Both Sides though surely
hey yeah why not yeah have you not
played any tight head I've played tight
in my earlier days are yeah close enough
yeah no true loose head prop I I did
know that to be fair I don't know why
I've put tight head but yeah Piggy's
gonna be filthy at me for that because I
love my props I love my right shoulder
down I love my messages that I get given
to um pass on to you guys so uh yeah
disappointing start but stoked to have
you on like I said not many guys um
thought I'd be able to get you on you
usually Dodge this stuff um but somehow
I've managed to rope you in here and
Greatful to have you on because you've
got such a cool unique story like a
different Pathway to most of the top uh
thanks for having me again man and uh
yeah as you said um I don't generally
like doing these sorts of things but uh
yeah I figured this is a pretty good
platform to just have a pretty lowkey
and sort of casual yarn about things and
yeah yeah well mate your career's been
um you must look back at your career
from where you were especially when you
first started I know you're a late
bloomer but um to what you've been able
to achieve winning Rugby World Cups won
about seven Super Rugby titles you must
look back on your career and and be
pretty proud of what you've done yeah
looking back on things there's uh
there's not too many uh regrets in there
yeah um there's been a lot of uh great
achievements through NPC titles through
country rugby titles um Super Rugby
titles yeah World Cup so it's uh it's
ticked a lot of boxers as far as that
goes um so yeah pretty happy with how
things have gone yeah not finished yet
though exactly there's still uh there's
still more to come yeah hopefully
another one um this year but let's get
to the start for you growing up um where
did you grow up somewhere in Christ
Church W you uh just out of Christ
Church in North Canterbury yeah uh sort
of in between wooden and Kaio um just on
a Wei Farm there um spent a lot of time
um over in towi that's where I went to
school uh that's where all my cousins
and everything were so um from school
and um sort of spending a lot of time
with my grandmother my to over there um
and playing around out on the m to on
the other side of things on uh back at
home um just parking up in the tractor
with dead so yeah um yeah had a pretty
pretty good sort of upbringing as a um
country kid and yeah yeah I re a lot of
people would see you as you know your
classic canabury farmer type upbringing
but you've got a significant moldy side
in your upbringing don't you you spent
like you said a lot of time at the marai
with your with your grandma and um the
rest of the cousins and stuff so that
was a big part of your upbringing wasn't
it yeah 100% um from most days after
school I'd be on my toll of just across
the road from the school so I'd be over
there waiting for you know Mom or Dad to
come pick me up and um yeah spending a
lot of time across the other side of the
road at the m and everything so I was
definitely a little pboy um growing up
and then yeah again just the rest of the
time I guess was spent with Dad out on
the tractor on the farm and bits and
pieces like that so yeah yeah and three
older sisters is it no no brothers no
brothers um yeah just the three older
sisters who for the most part were
pretty good to me but um also got picked
on a little bit by them and you know
there's a there's a couple of
incriminating photos floating around of
you know been doled up and there might
be a couple of dresses and whatnot there
but yeah CU most people obviously come
on here and they talk about the time
they spend in the backyard with their
brother and all that sort of helped them
get to um where they got to but you
obviously weren't outside playing
oneon-one footy with them you dressing
up and playing dolls with
them oh I don't know if it was quite
like that for the whole growing up sort
of period but um yeah there was a little
bit of it you know mixed in so yeah I'd
love to get my f hands on some of those
photos oh yeah if you actually talk to
any of them I'm sure they'd be
um it's very under the best but did you
play what when you went over to the
marah at where you sort of played or was
sport a big part of your upbringing
sport was a huge part of the upbringing
uh it wasn't so much the sports and
stuff over at the m and that was just um
kids being kids you know playing in the
bush and uh we had little dirt bike
tracks and stuff out the back and
whatever um but I've tried my hand at
pretty much every sport we could um
Growing Up So played a little bit of
cricket a little bit of uh touch rugby
rugby league actually was um yeah I
started as a Ley I didn't really
transfer over to rugby until uh High
School sort of period oh true that late
um yeah literally just had to crack at
everything growing up so yeah and
wrestling how did you get into wrestling
because we all know you're World Junior
World Champ at wrestling or
something uh I think that sort of
started as I was roughly I think I was
about seven and um I was just I was a
little bit of a naughty kid at school
and um what sort of stuff were you doing
oh just a bit of extra energy you know
like um playing up and having a few
rumbles with other kids and whatnot so
got taken got taken to the local
wrestling club and
um yeah uh at first I think it was just
an extra Outlet to sort of try and drain
the juice a bit and you know um but
ended up loving it so stuck with it
until yeah I was about 21 I think was
when I sort of uh finished up with the
wrestling and just started fully
concentrating on Rugby but yeah between
that period from 7 to 21
uh yeah I went to a to a heap of
tournaments and um wrestling actually
took me a we way around the world with
um different bits and pieces and
tournaments around the place so uh yeah
were you good at that as soon as you
started or like how how did that
progress um I don't know that I was
particularly good at it when I started
but uh just enjoyed it I guess um and
then yeah through a bit of dedication
and um you know hard work and training
and stuff um and the enjoyment of it all
uh just started becoming better and
better sort of thing and by the time I
was at high school I was yeah relatively
good so yeah was it ever a career path
for you did you ever want to go down the
the wrestling route uh it was kind of an
option for a while yeah
um like when I was coming to the end of
high school I had a couple of
opportunities where I could have gone to
uh Canada or the states for um for
University scholarships and that to
carry on with the the wrestling Journey
but um at that time in my life I wasn't
real keen on doing that so um yeah
that's kind of part of uh why I decided
to sort of give it away and start start
um pursuing the rugby path yeah what
kept you here what was it was it
something was it about rugby was it the
individual sport what what was it that
made you turn that down um I guess part
of it was just really that I'm a I'm a
big homie you know like just love being
in Canterbury I guess and um that's
where that's where my family is and
that's where my my friends are and
everything so it's just um yeah I just
wanted to I didn't really want to leave
all that behind at that time and um yeah
I guess that's part of what what's kept
me here in the red and black as well
just um yeah this is home so yeah don't
want to leave fair enough and you like
you're wrestling you did go around the
world like you won Oceana TI Oceania
titles didn't you yeah one a few Oceania
titles and uh both greo and freestyle uh
both in Junior and senior as well um
yeah so what senior what age is that uh
so junior is 17 to 21 yeah and then yeah
senior just yeah 21 to yeah basically
just grade so so you won that yeah jeez
at 21 you must have been no I think I
won my first Oceania uh senior title
when I was I think I was still in the
Juniors I was 17 oh
wow you must have been good then and
then did you go to a world time title uh
I did go to the junior World Champs um
but it was a knockout tournament and I
got cleaned up by this Indian fell who
ended up getting I think he was third so
um yeah so I just I ended up getting
15th on the points I scored on him sort
of thing so that's how they and was he
your first match up he was my the first
match up went over to China for the
junior World Champs um yeah got him in
my first match scored a few points on
him but he won um yeah so that was me D
and Dustin oh one and
done yeah and how does that work did you
know he was a a good wrestler the Indian
guy or you pretty confident going into
it do you do your research at um sort of
stuff at that point in time there wasn't
really anything of you know footage and
stuff that you could sort of go back and
watch so I was going in pretty blind on
things um just the fact that he was
Indian I knew that he would have been
pretty good cuz Indian India is a wrestl
yeah pretty strong strong country for
for wrestling
um yeah and then I think yeah he came
third uh I know Ukrainian guy won it and
I can't remember where the guy was that
came second oh yeah yeah if he had made
it into the finals I would have had a
rer charge match and you know would have
got my rankings off a bit oh okay um
yeah he lost one of those guys is what
it is so yeah so then your decision to
move into to rugby um you didn't want to
leave so you probably couldn't progress
much in your wrestling here in New
Zealand um rugby seemed just a normal
Choice was it kind of like um growing up
and everything uh my dream when I was a
kid was I wanted to play for the kiwis
oh yeah and then uh once I sort of
transferred over to rugby um yeah that
changed from the kiwis to the old blacks
and then um I guess even through High
School it was you know I was I I didn't
know exactly what I wanted to do whether
I was going to chase the wrestling or
rugby or something but I knew I wanted
to be in sports still yeah um and then
yeah when when it came to that decision
time um yeah I just felt like the the
rugby side of things was a was the
better option for me to to try chasing
even though I hadn't you know I didn't
have a foot on the door as such with um
I never made any of those um New Zealand
secondary schools or anything like that
at high school um yeah what school did
did you go there I was at Christ College
oh Christ College yeah and you're
playing first 15 for them yep I'd played
two years first 15 at Christ did you
make the Crusaders region schools team
no didn't make Southern regions or
anything like that so like yeah like I
was saying I didn't make any of the
representative sides when I was at
school what' you go like at
League
uh oh I probably thought I was all right
what position were you at um back in
those days I was uh a bit leaner in Mina
I was I played a little bit on the
centers and back row yeah oh yeah yeah
played a bit of everything yeah so then
when you moved to Union was it straight
into the front row uh no when I first
came into rugby I was playing uh number
eight I play played a little bit of Huer
actually um I played a little bit of
prop but yeah I was mainly number eight
I guess and when when did your move make
the full commitment to prop because I
think everyone wants to be a loose
when did you make the dreaded decision
even you I could imagine you don't
really love being in there do you I do
now but I didn't at the time um it it
all sort of came about to be honest um
Matt ston he was um he was a big one for
um I guess my career path and starting
me off um cuz he was the academy manager
and that at the time and um he he'd come
and seen me at Club 40 and everything
and uh he hit me up one day and said um
look we've got a spot for you in the
academy but it's on the condition that
you convert from number eight to prop oh
yeah and I just sort of screwed my face
up at him a little bit and I was like oh
really uh look I'll get back to you in a
couple weeks or something eh and um gave
it a bit of thought and you know I
thought well [__] Rugby's what I want to
chase as the dream and everything um
yeah let's give it a crack so got back
to him and uh said yep let's let's do it
sort of thing and um I guess yeah
haven't really looked back since then
converted over to prop and chipped the
way through the academy and um yeah from
the
academy uh I was still playing country
footy and um I wasn't making it um how
long's this time frame this was uh 3
years cuz um the spot that he told me
was in the academy it was actually the
pre-academy oh okay so I did a year in
the pre-academy I did my two years in
the academy and um yeah I was playing
for linking
country uh still couldn't crack crack
into the canib scene
um and then yeah Matt six and the few
others had all sort of said to me that
you know if you want to crack into it
and make the next level you're going to
have to play in town to you know to get
there play against the opposition that
you're going to be competing against or
competing for the spot for I said oh
yeah r i stuck like I tried not to as
long as I could but um I ended up going
to town went went and played for Lincoln
uni and uh I still didn't crack into it
playing that season in town so I sort of
you know snubbed my nose at them and
said buggies then and went back to
Country footy after that true um so went
back to Lincoln um and then I made it
into Canterbury that year from from
Lincoln country when you went back yeah
yeah so yeah that's I guess the that's
the start of how everything sort of
cranked into the high gear for me with
you know um professional footy how hard
was that to learn um the craft of a
front rower like going from number eight
to you you spoke about I think was about
four years now like when did you feel
like you you sort of got your head
around being a front row and especially
scrum time um In fairness I I still
learn things now yeah but in those first
few years uh it was such a massive
learning curve um
from basically getting thrown into the
front row and just thinking you know
I've just got to literally hold up a
scrum to learning all the the finite
intricacies of things and the dark arts
you know
um from the difference and scrummaging
from Club footy uh to NPC is a huge jump
and then the from NPC to Super Rugby is
another massive jump I feel like that
was the biggest uh that was the biggest
jump from NPC to Super
Rugby um and then from Super Rugby to
International there was another another
jump again but I don't think it was
probably as big as the the shock from
NPC to Super yeah yeah so yeah each
level that you kept going up it was you
know different things different um
different bits and pieces of you know
knowledge and whatever that you had to
do for technique and everything uh
different pressures you know obviously
as you get to the international stage
it's just um well big powerful men uh a
lot of pressure on you um and everyone
knows exactly what they're doing so um
yeah that's obviously you know the
toughest toughest spot but um how much
of it can people tell you or how much of
it do you have to be in
it uh it definitely helps when people
can tell you bits and pieces you get
into it so you canat practice it and try
and replicate it before you get into you
know the real scenario um but there's
always going to be that certain amount
of it that you you can't really
comprehend until you've actually gotten
fully uh in the mixer with it and done
it done it to experience it yeah yeah so
when you make
your debut for canib are you feeling
confident and comfortable at that stage
I suppose you had to wait so you're
probably ready for the opportunity but
you feeling confident yeah relatively um
I guess I was I guess I had sort of a
false confidence as well you know going
from um from Club footy and everything
to Canterbury and and just because I
didn't know I guess so I had that little
bit of a a false confidence I guess but
um yeah you soon get brought brought
down to earth when you come up against
some Wy old heads and um yeah get taught
a couple of lessons who were some of
those guys that got you early on that
you remember um I actually remember
Chris King was one of them so ended up
playing with M playing alongside him um
but yeah coming up against him I think
he was playing uh
tanaki um yeah
just you get a few lessons uh through
some Wy old tight here namia Tada uh you
know i' been watching him through the
All Blacks and everything and then
coming up against him for Canter and
Wellington games um yeah it's just I
guess some of the hidings that you get
are actually the best um best teaching
tools that you can get as well you know
so it's um yeah all those have sort of
developed me into becoming a bit of prop
yeah is there any games where you just
feel like you can't like really match
them at scrum time and you really want
to be avoiding
them um especially early on I'm
guessing honestly I can't quite think of
any at loose head when I've been there
but um as we sort of touched on in the
intro thinks um yeah did play a little
bit at tight head yeah there we go and
uh when I got thrown into tight head um
man uh one of our games was up in
Hamilton against the Chiefs and uh I
think I was on the bench this was before
we had a prop to cover both sides so he
just had one on the bench that had cover
both and that was me at that time um and
Owen Franks went off in the blood bin uh
so I had to come on at tight head and
the chief's uh loose head was poim Manu
oh yeah uh he was a very good very good
loose head um and I remember it came to
scrum time and I was just popped
straight out the sunroof and I was
looking up at the stands like geez this
is a nice view
so and I was just just every time that
anything happened and uh you know that
we were going to scrum time I was like
ah
[__] here we go
again
oh yeah must be an awful feeling is that
the worst thing like getting popped is
is what's the worst thing for a prop to
happen to them yeah to be fair I don't
think there's too much worse than that
getting popped at the top yeah true up
the sunroof and you're just poking out
there your head's up there and the rest
of the scrums down underneath you and
you're just enjoying the view you
know yeah and then how many years was it
from canb till the Crusaders I know you
said that was the biggest um jump for
you at scrum time what how long was that
transition um so my first year was 2011
with NPC with Canterbury yeah uh and
then the following season uh I made the
wider Squad with Crusaders through 2012
but I didn't actually uh make the full
squad or play for crusaders until 2013
true no injuries in prop that year jesz
times have changed yeah tell me about
it so when you made your debut at Super
Rugby you you were ready this time yep
you felt ready the same confidence but
you obviously felt the biggest jump um
at scrum time yeah uh but fortunately
you know like I'd had that um I guess
that that period through the wider
training Squad where I'd been
scrummaging against the best you know we
had um at that point in time at
Crusaders we had the likes of white
Crockett both the Frank's Brothers been
yeah um yeah we had an awesome awesome
pack sort of thing so um getting to sort
of do my apprenticeship under those guys
uh you couldn't ask for much more so
yeah by the time I actually did debut
with Super Rugby I felt like i' served a
pretty good apprenticeship and I was uh
not falsely confident this time like I
was with NPC but I just I was relatively
confident um yeah just through through
training and everything that I I knew I
was I knew I was ready yeah how
important is that for a prop to have
other props to scrummage against during
the week good props um honestly I think
it's like you can't really uh calculate
the value of it just cuz it's it's
invaluable it's um to have a to have
another pack to scrum against through
the week to prepare you for the weekend
uh that's really strong um like that's
just h i yeah I don't know how to
describe it but it's a gym you know like
if you have a [__] [__] opposition to
practice with against through the week
and then you're coming up against a
strong uh a strong pack on the
weekend um you go undercooked and you're
not very well prepared whereas you know
it as it happens here we still have
really strong uh strong reserves and
strong started starting pack whichever
side you're in so um normally our
training scrums and everything that we
have uh here through the week now are
generally speaking um tougher than what
we end up finding in the games so yeah I
think yeah that's that's a real gem that
we've got going on here yeah that's
interesting and you you must have felt
at times last year when we were seven
props down you must have been going into
a few of those games feeling like you
hadn't quite got the prep that you'd
normally got yeah sometimes I guess but
at the same time at the start of the
season when I was still playing uh we we
sure you were gone by then yeah
unfortunately I ended up being one of
those one of those seven props down so
um yeah at the start of the season when
I was still playing yeah we still had a
really good um both sides so yeah it
wasn't until later on when I was one of
the one of the casualties I guess that
we might have been struggling and
getting a few uh new faces in and that
sort of carry on so you've been here
with the Crusaders I mean I think the
first few years you hadn't won a
competition yeah and then the last seven
you have managed to win it what was sort
of the turning point there what you from
being inside what was sort of the
difference for you um a lot changed uh I
guess it's it's really hard just to put
your finger on one specific thing but um
like in those earlier years you know we
had we had a great side uh we had some
great players but we were still losing
the title you know we had the rich
mcalls and the Dan Carters and we were
still losing um and
then after losing those players and then
winning the titles and that um it
was I guess a little bit of the
environment changed um and that's not
because those players win or anything
that's not at all what I was trying to
say there um just yeah I guess with the
Scott Robertson takeover he kind of
created a different sort of working
environment um we had a lot of fun uh
whereas things before that had been
quite sort of strict and um it was a it
was a workplace and you here to work
work and you're here to grind you know
uh and then yeah he just kind of created
a culture where um where it was fun to
come to work but at the same time you
still you still had to grind and you
still had to you know do the tough stuff
but um yeah that just the whole culture
I guess brought everyone together a bit
tighter and uh I guess that was that was
part of it but uh not you know not the
complete reason why we started winning
titles otherwise we' just be I don't
know having piss-ups mid week and that's
crazy though seven titles is pretty
incredible and you've been here for all
of them it's um it's been pretty special
seven years being a crusader yeah it's
been a hell of a time especially it it
makes it even uh that little bit more
special uh the fact that I I'd been here
before um you know when we were well
when we rather than say when we were
losing but when we weren't winning
titles yeah
yeah yeah um and any of those that stand
out for you what's what's been your
favorite title I think my favorite one
has definitely got to be the first one
the first one over in Johannesburg uh
you know they talk about it as um no
other Su no Super Rugby team had ever
done that gone and and won away from
home and the fact that it was in
Johannesburg uh it just yeah it was huge
you know like driving in on the bus and
um they're banging on the bus they love
it just screaming at us they're going to
kill you you know like and they're like
giving the whole throat slitting uh
gestures and everything to us as we come
in on the and on the bus it was a pretty
hostile sort of crowd and everything but
um yeah when we won man it was just a it
was just a really sweet feeling you know
did you start that one yeah yeah what
What U minute did you came off cuz I
remember them coming home with a real
wet sale uh I think generally speaking I
was around the 60 60 Minute Max yeah so
were you confident you you done enough
you were you were always going to win
that one cuz you had a pretty big lead
for most of it but then I think they
scored a few late tries and yeah got
pretty close in the end yeah no I think
from memory um I was always confident
yeah uh yeah again we had a we had an
awesome team that year um just yeah
every everything that we did that day I
think sort of almost came off for us you
know from set's bloody 70 odd meter try
or whatever from picking up a loose ball
and whatnot um yeah everything just sort
of went our way and um yeah made for a
pretty pretty fun trip home yeah I've
heard about that trip home where were
you at there you would have been right
at the front first
class yeah well I think fortunately uh
yeah you know all those long haes we get
to go business class and whatnot so
yeah
still yeah
oh and then you move into the All Blacks
like um you mentioned at the start that
it was a gol of yours early on or
basically as soon as you switched over
to rugby um how did you find out that
you had achieved that guy become an all
black
um oh this is a yeah interesting one I
guess um I'd been doing dress up
again not quite um I was actually I was
loving with Sam wh loock um at the time
and uh I'd been out uh had had a good
night out after one of our Crusader
games and I was pretty dusty so I was in
bed real early I think [__] about I
don't know 6:30 7:00 that's how dusty
sort of thing I was um and then my phone
started going off I was like and it was
a random number so um I I almost didn't
answer it and then I thought oh get
answer see who it is um and yeah it was
Darren Shan the all black manager yeah
um telling me that uh yeah they wanted
me to come into the squad and um yeah
train with them in that and I was kind
of thinking is this a prank call I was
trying to make out if this was any of my
mates disguising their voice sort of
thing trying to you know just just get
me and uh no sure enough it wasn't so um
yeah was sort of that was my first sort
of introduction or that was my first
call or whatever from the ABS and so you
getting called into a camp it wasn't the
official announcement was it yeah it was
yeah exactly what you said yeah just
called into Camp um to start training
that with them and
um so that was in 2013 my first year of
Super Rugby um quick yeah and
uh I ended up getting named for the uh
for the end of year tour um that year in
2013 um and I was pretty fizzed up for
that uh but first things first we um we
had to play the play the NPC final um
Can vers Wellington up at the Kon yeah
and uh I think it came to about 55
minutes in uh so yeah that's just about
when I'm about to go off for smoko
anyway and uh I got tackled
and the guy sort of swung around uh
swung around me and landed on my leg
funny and snapped my leg and blew out my
ankle so um yeah I was in hospital uh
getting my x-rays and they said yeah
it's definitely you know bugger and
whatnot so and I was supposed to yes I
was supposed to be flying out the next
morning to go to Japan for this uh for
the start of the end year
tour um and that sort of that that was
that for 2013 brutal how hard was it for
you to take because obviously dream to
be in all you've got your opportunity
you're playing in a final about to come
off and snap absolutely gutted oh it was
pretty Bittersweet cuz canbury we we won
the final uh so he got the you know got
the gold medal for the NPC final um and
then at the same time I was um yeah
pretty devastated as well uh that I
wasn't going to be getting on the plane
the next day uh heading to Japan so
um yeah it was a pretty tough pill to
swallow but at the same time um I knew I
was kind of there or thereabout so um
yeah didn't throw a pity party or
anything for myself tried to enjoy the
celebrations with the canbury boys for
the next couple of days with a a
throbbing leg that was in cast and
everything but um yeah and then as soon
as I got out of that cast um yeah I was
just trying to keep motivated to keep
training and uh get back in there for
for 2014 which um which I did end up um
debuting and and getting amongst it then
so yeah so it was a case of once you
became fit you you were selectable for
the or blacks and you were selected for
the or blacks again yeah yeah how good
and then what was that debut like uh
again that was kind of a bit of sweet
one too like I was on I was on Cloud9
you know like just made my debut for the
All Blacks but uh we drew with Aussie
and it was the end of the unbeaten uh 18
in a row run oh true so the boys were
all in the sheds you know like you could
hear a pin drop type setup and then
there's me with a bloody grin from ear
to a I was just like
yeah just played my first game for the
AVS because my family had flown over as
well it was in Sydney oh yeah so they'd
come over to watch and yeah just made a
bit of a cameo Off the Bench and how
long did you get oh I can't remember
exactly how long it was somewhat of a
cameo I think it was only
maybe uh maybe 15 minutes or something
at the end but yeah how'd you go out the
hucker I know your proud moldy um the
hucker was an interesting one because uh
back then when I first made it we didn't
really have any hucker practices and
that like they they do now uh it was
just kind of um I asked a couple of the
older guys oh what's the go with the Hy
you know like do we do a do we do a
practice or anything like that and
they're like no no mate you just need to
get on YouTube and watch it so really
scratcher said the same thing when he
came on he had to learn it off YouTube I
can't believe that um as an all black
going to do a hucker you had to learn
the hacker off of YouTu yeah was it Kam
yeah it was just Kam then uh but yeah it
was
uh yeah I just went into my room and I
was had my headphones on and I was just
watching it over and over and yeah sweet
how did you know where to stand or like
how do you know where to go or you just
get shuffled to wherever back then it
was kind of yeah just Shuffle around
wherever but now it's um everyone's got
spots and um yeah got the formation and
whatnot um they always have a have a
hucker practice whether it be on the um
Captain's run day or um you know one
night through the week or whatever but
uh yeah it was definitely an interesting
sort of setup I was almost more nervous
about doing the hucker than I was the
game kind of thing like you wouldn't
yeah didn't want to [__] that up but
yeah oh crack up and and did you feel
comfortable in the all black environment
did you feel confident in it um I don't
know if I'd say I felt confident or
comfortable in it uh when I first came
in I was pretty nervous coming into Camp
you know there's all these like real big
dog names and you're just this young
fellow uh you know when I first came in
there was the Andrew hes and Tony
Woodcock the Richie mcco Dan Carters you
know Mar nonu Conrad Smith all those
guys were in there um so yeah I was just
trying to basically keep my head down
don't [__] up anything don't be late to
any meetings you know um and just yeah
just go hard when it came to whenever I
got any opportunities you know so yeah
you speak about a lot of those players
and I know most of them were in that
2015 Rugby World Cup squad and you had a
different journey to to get there you
got there in the end but um talk me
through how you got over to the Rugby
World C yeah well I suppose that all
started from uh uh from my 2014 season
um so I had I think I had a relatively
good season in 2014 but then um given
the break that the the All Blacks get
over the offseason you know not having
to do the team pre-season and everything
uh that was kind of my first time uh
with that and not having to do the
preseason with the team
so um I had a major slip up there and I
just took it as
uh downtime holiday time you know like I
didn't really train through that
offseason so I came into 2015 uh way out
of shape uh not in very good neck uh Mr
blackader toy was not happy with me at
all um so I wasn't getting um a lot of
game time with Crusaders you know Croy
was getting all the all the time and
um yeah I didn't end up uh getting
selected for that initial 2015 um World
Cup squad
um and yeah I had no one to blame for
that but myself because I hadn't put
myself in the in the right State uh I
wasn't fit and I was overweight and all
that um but at the same time I guess uh
it may have been too little too late but
um it kind of cracked the whip on me and
man the amount of extras that I was
doing to try and get fit at that point
uh after every single training at
Canterbury I was doing extra running and
just yeah whatever I could off feet
sessions um to try and you know trim up
get fit and be ready just in case uh it
all kind of paid off cuz
um yeah come the quarterfinals of That
World Cup uh I think Woody Tony Woodcock
had um he had already gone out injured
but um they hadn't bought in a
replacement for him uh oh no sorry sorry
Woody got injured so they bought in
bought me in as a replacement
uh and I was kind of thinking I wasn't
going to get any game time or anything
because they already had uh Ben Franks
over there as well who played both so I
just figured you know the natural
progression was um that'd bring him in
uh to the to the 23 and I'd just be a
hit bag holder you know just the the
extra guy um but yeah I flew over there
in that um quarterfinal week against
France um and yeah I was named on the
bench I was like Wow [__] right straight
in there yeah um and then crocky got
injured uh H as uh H as groin I think it
was in the first 20 minutes of that um
France game in the quarterfinal so yeah
I was on for 60 minutes for the
quarterfinals
um I started the next week against South
Africa in the semis and then started in
the finals against Australia so crazy
hey what a turnaround what a year
yeah yeah actually so no I was pretty
pretty happy with how it all turned out
cuz uh if I'm really honest with you uh
getting that call up to the 2015 World
Cup I was almost in two minds about it
cuz uh I thought man I'm playing really
good footy here with canbury I'm having
an awesome time you know um starting
consistent game time and all that um and
then I'm going to have to go over here
uh literally not play any games just be
hit bag holder and you know just be that
extra Guy this is going to be [__] sort
of thing you
know [__] I landed there named in the
named in the squad to play in the
quarterfinal and then played quarter
semis and finals it was just w we you
know all imagine if you turned it down
and you saw the another guy do that
starting in a World Cup final yeah I
know would yeah that wouldn't have uh
that wouldn't have gone down great
what when did you know you'd sort of
stuffed up in that offseason or like uh
what point did you realize oh I haven't
I have blown out here um I think it
probably wasn't until a couple of weeks
out from the season when we were playing
preseason games and
uh and I just kind of thought my fitness
and everything was magically going to
come and it didn't we're playing these
preseason games and I was just
absolutely shagged and um yeah I was
like wow I've not not gone good here
like yeah that that was a mess of
learning curve for me uh cuz I haven't
done it again since but um yeah yeah got
to go through it sometimes to learn yeah
yeah yeah but that that World Cup side
people still talk about it as
potentially the best side ever put on
paper um and your name's part of it it
must be pretty crazy eh yeah uh to be
fair I haven't heard too much chat about
it but um I guess when you do look at it
you know like what I sort of mentioned
coming into the squad and everything it
does have some real Legends of the game
in that in that 2015 squ so um yeah
it'll be a tough one to beat everyone in
their Prime sort of thing yeah what did
those guys do well you know those those
legends that you have spoken about like
um I guess they they enforced they
enforced a really good culture on the
team you know like um the young guys
coming into the squad you know like how
I was saying I just wanted to keep my
head down not [__] up and whatever like
everyone that came into the squad
whether you're a younger guy in the
middle or whatever you know the the the
older sort of we call it the back seat
um the back of the bus you know they
were just every no one wanted to [__] up
because no one wanted to have to deal
with you know these guys down the back
of the bus yeah and uh I think that was
really good having that little bit of a
sense of fear almost you know um within
the squad because in recent times being
in the team
um you know without naming names or
saying incidents or whatever uh there
has been a lot of cock-ups that would
have never happened or that did never
happen you know back in uh back in the
early days with with abs and that so um
I think that's one of the one of the key
things that I guess you know those older
guys did sort of do or have yeah I guess
everyone who came out had so much
respect for these these guys they just
the last thing they wanted to do was was
let them down exactly yeah yeah it's
interesting and then let's fast forward
to the
2019 Rugby World Cup um you'd made made
yourself pretty much a lock in there at
loose head prop going into it so you
were confident going into that World Cup
you were going to be named and no no
issues uh yeah I didn't think there was
going to be too much as far as uh being
named around it and everything went
um any anxiety around a late injury
leading up to it in all honesty even
with my shocking run of injuries uh I
never really have any anxiety around
getting injured you know like um you
always just go out there and you just
want to play and you want to do what
you've got to do exact uh you know so
you never really have that uh you never
have that thought in the back of your
mind um about being or getting injured
or having an injury and trying to
preserve yourself for for anything else
that's going to come later yeah because
if if you start doing that or playing
like that you're just going to play [__]
and it's you know and you'll get injured
yeah either you'll get injured or you
just won't get picked for the next thing
cuz you're playing [__]
so that's very true so once you got over
to Japan um how' you find it how was
that World Cup how did it compare
uh the Japan World Cup was different in
the aspect of uh it was really hot and
it was real sticky like
um I remember I had to get all this uh
the old athletes foot cream and stuff
cuz I was getting the old fungus gr
between the toes and
whatnot yeah yeah it was so hot when we
were training so your feet were always
just like um they were always wet cu the
the grass like the fields you train on
would be wet as well and then with the
heat on top of that yeah it was just uh
yeah one of one of the things we had to
deal with but um other than that uh yeah
other than the bit of heat and whatnot
um there was a pretty good feeling
within the squad uh I think we were
playing we actually played some pretty
good footy uh up until you know that
Dreadful sort of uh semi-final where we
got absolutely rolled by England um
yeah it was just one of those things you
know like they played probably one of
their best games and we played probably
one of our worst games which is you know
not trying to defend us ourselves or
anything but um that's just kind of the
way footy goes sometimes it's not that
we were undercooked or we' been playing
up or anything like that it's just um it
was just kind of one of those things and
especially how World Cup works so
everyone was pretty gutted and down
about things after that game but um
in all honesty like no one wanted no one
wants to play off for third and fourth
you know like yeah um so having to stay
on after we lost against England and
stay on for that that last week to play
in the third and fourth playoff like
that whole week was just kind of a why
are we here you know yeah and it wasn't
actually until um it wasn't until we
were on the bus driving to the game for
that third and fourth playoff uh it sort
of clicked in my head it's another one
of the tour buses went past us and all
the New Zealand fans were out the window
with their flags and waving to us and
stuff I was like wow this game actually
does still mean something to a lot of
people I [__] I need to pull my head in
and flick the switch here so um yeah and
then we ended up playing some really
good footy in that um in that third and
fourth playoff and rolled Wales and yeah
yeah but unfortunately it was a bit too
little too late we should have done it
the week before against England
so yeah how hard is it post a World Cup
to obviously it's a four-year cycle how
hard is it post World Cup to um I guess
get back on the horse and get motivated
again uh as far as the international
stuff goes um for me personally I've
always been kind of one that just almost
takes things day by day so at the End of
the World Cup you know I wouldn't even
think about uh the international
seasoning at that point it be like oh
yeah right so next jobs with Crusaders
don't blow out in the off seon exactly
yeah yeah so it'll be right so I've got
to get my preseason training program and
everything sorted for um coming into
coming into the next year uh hot so that
it's not going to take me half the half
the super season to to get fit and all
all the rest of it so um yeah that that
my always been my mentality around
things but um yeah I don't I don't know
if other people different with it or
what it's a good mentality to have I
think um it's it's the right one to have
and then let's go to 2023 this one
probably a little bit more disappointing
but um you're playing so well in Super
Rugby you pick up an injury yeah um and
I guess you sort of run out of time to
put your hand up is that how you saw it
yeah well basically um this this year
and missing out on uh well last year
sorry um missing out on the the World
Cup selection and that for
2023 uh I've only really got two big
regrets throughout my uh rugby career uh
the 2023 World Cup missing out on that
that's one of them and uh the drawn line
series is the other one yeah but um yeah
honestly I was I was so devastated uh
when I got the phone call the night
before team naming um that yeah they
weren't taking me I was yeah I was
honestly I was I couldn't be talked to
for a while I just I just wanted to be
by myself and just sort of simmer and
let everything process for a bit but um
yeah when when I first got injured uh
through the through the season
um I was straight to the doctors and
everything and the medical team to um
start making my plan for rehabbing and
wanted to get all my dates in a line to
see when I'd be back and ready to play
and all that sort of carry on
uh just to make sure that I was I was
going to have enough time to make a make
a run for selection you know and then
uh as it worked out I was still going to
have enough time to you know uh be ready
and get back into it um and then
unfortunately uh so that was an ankle
surgery that I had and then I was coming
back from that and starting back with my
running and everything and then I
tweaked my calf and then that put me
back another couple of weeks so that was
kind of almost the straw that broke the
camels back then cuz um yeah the way
that I was explained everything was um
yeah I needed to have some more footy
coming into the World Cup and uh needed
to be match match fit and match ready
and they didn't think I was going to be
ready for test match footy for those uh
opening pool games so yeah that's the
way they saw it and I guess at the end
of the day that's all that counts cuz
that's not quite how I saw things
but yeah feel felt like you'd done
enough to to be on that plan to yeah in
all honesty I like I did I thought that
my super my super performances had uh
had probably done enough to you know
still get me uh still get me in the
team um and then yeah from the the the
non- selection man it was tough um like
I didn't want to be a um you you know
any sort of uh negative Nell or anything
you know and uh be down in the dumps
around the can boys or anything like
that uh so I was doing my best to try
and stay motivated and um you know train
well and play well and everything for
canbury but uh it was easier said than
done you know like um the reality of it
was
uh yeah I I was just so devastated about
everything I basically
I basically did mope a bit and uh washed
my hands a little bit of 2023 um I
trained [__] for canabury I played
played [__] for Canterbury um and yeah I
basically just rode off the 2023 uh
season um and just yeah couldn't wait
for 24 to roll over so he could take in
and uh kick in and start fresh and just
um yeah I guess um rip into the 24
season and um I guess prove a point
point it's good honesty did you were you
the next guy in line to be caught up I
remember you being pulled out of a NPC
game everyone's like Joe Moody's on the
plane he's going to be this is 2015 all
over again you're going to be starting
in the final what happened um yeah oh
yeah well that's what D told me
basically was that if any props got
injured whatever side it was that yeah
I'd be you know straight on the
flame um and then yeah I did get pulled
out of uh one of the canbury games I
can't what was that canbury vers ockland
I think it was here in Canterbury
um but uh yeah at the end of the day
uh everyone had their theories on things
and started rumors and whatnot and I'd
get a thousand texts oh mate I heard
you're on the plane yeah you know and
getting all those messages uh it didn't
help with my heads space either you know
trying to actually motivated and in a
good and everything um but yeah at the
same time I knew people were only just
trying to um you know be pumped for me
and that sort of thing even if they were
misinformed and you know on the wrong
track with things but yeah I couldn't
get angry at anyone for the for the
messages but at the same time I I
actually I was getting a bit pissed off
with getting all these messages and
whatnot um but yeah so you were pulled
out that game as a precaution or you
were never actually told you were going
over yeah uh so the call that I got was
from jce Ryan just saying look we've got
a couple of um issues with two of our
props with Karen niggles um if anything
happens to them in this game you'll be
on the next flight coming over yeah um
and then that game uh two of the props
actually went off uh with injuries
that's right and
uh yeah I literally didn't hear another
word from them that was it so never said
that you're they're good to go n never
got any don't worry they good US Gold
never got any yeah they bugged would you
to have pack your bags just in case it
was literally radio silence you know
didn't I that after the phone call that
pulled me out of the game and everything
uh that was literally it that was the
last I heard from from anyone uh in the
All Blacks uh you know coaching and
management so that's interesting eh yeah
and if if you did go over did you feel
like you're in a good enough head space
were you ready to perform oh if if I'd
been given the tick as far as uh then
went um yeah I it wouldn't be hard to
flick the switch As far as the mental
head space went then cuz um like again
going into that whole uh Team selection
SL non selection I was in I was in the
best shape of my life you know my my
skin folds were pretty much
uh my weight everything strength Fitness
everything was going good coming through
that um coming back from that
injury um I'd been so Vigilant with
everything my diet all my training you
know I'd been going so hard because
everything that I was um all my goals
everything that I was looking forward to
was basically that World Cup and I knew
that the the injury that I'd got um you
know was basically making things harder
for me by not being able to have that
game time and not being able to have
that lead in to to World Cup selection
so I was training my ass off I was uh I
was so focused you know um everything
that I was doing was literally just
working towards um go getting on that
plane and then uh yeah that was the yeah
like I said before you know getting that
phone call saying that I wasn't going it
was just like boom everything I'd been
working for for this whole the whole
year or I guess the past 3 years four
years whatever was basically just all
you know flushed down the toilet and on
top of that uh you know on top of all
the selfish stuff for me as well like um
all the comms that I'd had were pretty
positive as well so I told my I told my
mom that um yeah don't worry like I'm in
lock it in so she had booked all her
flights accommodation all this other
stuff to go over there as well so then
on top of that when I got the call
saying I wasn't and just like oh man
like how am I like how am I going to
tell Mom now I like you know she's yeah
spent all this money to go over and
follow me over to France and whatnot did
she go yeah she ended up going um she
yeah she still went to what did she go
to she went to the quarterfinal and the
um final um so yeah she got to a couple
of the games as well yeah yeah I think
she had a great time and I wasn't
playing but I think at the same time she
wouldn't have gone she wasn't going to
be G but yeah oh that's funny and then
you spoke about wiping uh the floor with
2023 and now you're in 2024 and this is
what you're looking forward to so um
you're in offseason now no blowouts um
so far looking forward to the to the
year ahead yeah definitely um like I
said earlier it's just I've got a real
point to prove this year so
um yeah I've got to just keep working
hard uh smashing out that Fitness and
everything um yeah then just come into
the season hot so uh yeah just get rid
of any naysayers get rid of that monkey
off my back and yeah um yeah just have
an awesome awesome 2024 and you got a
good crew of um props I guess coming
through and in the Crusaders you got
Owen coming back who youve obviously
spent a lot of time with throughout the
years but um the growth of T and um
flicky um how do you think they're
going those those young Fells are going
real good so that's uh kind of like what
I touched on at the start you know
having um having the the good uh the
good packs to prop against so um whether
it's the old boys um or the young fellas
as long as they're going good it's uh
yeah it doesn't matter what sort of
personnel you Chuck in the pack you know
you've you've got a good back so yeah
yeah so what's motivating you to keep
going obviously getting what are you now
35 yeah same age as me what's um what's
motivating you to still keep going uh
still I'm still chasing that uh cherry
out in front of me I guess of the black
Jersey um so yeah I'm wanting to I'm
wanting to go out I guess basically on
top I suppose
um yeah I I don't want to I don't want
to be one of those guys that just hangs
in there basically uh trying to collect
a paycheck and um you know play the odd
game here and there um I want to be I
want to be the first first pick um prop
you know you're you're writing out your
team sheet and uh luciid prop there's
not even a second thought boom Joe Moody
um so yeah I I want to be at the top of
my game um cuz yeah I don't know if we
were going to get into this on today's
chat but I'd say you know this will be
my last year in New Zealand anyway uh
whether or not come the end of this
year um I Look to maybe do a season or
two overseas before I finish things off
or just call it a day at the end of this
year I'll see but um fire out there we
go it's an announcement you heard it
here first what a exclusive but um yeah
I don't know we we'll see how the season
plays out I guess um but I can't imagine
um I can't imagine you know I'll be back
here next year unless um unless you guys
start bigging Me For You Know Dan pan
will be on his knees after he hears
this but you know with with the way that
we've got this uh young stock coming
through and everything here you know
it's probably probably time to hand the
torch over sort of thing and uh but yeah
it's uh it's not something that I just
want to give them for U 20125 it's
something they have to earn and take but
um yeah yeah again it's all it's all
about how I want to I want to play the
some of the best footy I've ever played
sort of thing come 2024 and really prove
a point so yeah I love it and has there
ever been that temptation to go overseas
um throughout your career you've you
said that you're a homeboy I'm guessing
that's been a big part of you staying
but I'm sure you've had offers from the
French and UK Japanese potentially as
well throughout your time um yeah
there's been a there's been a few
opportunities uh through the middle of
my career and actually right at the
start as well oh yeah um so right from
when I was just uh Crusaders WI a
training Squad um Matt ston you know who
had picked me up through the academy and
everything he got the role as a um
Southern Kings coach over in
Australia Australia South Africa and uh
and he threw a contract at me you know
cuz I was only wide a training Squad
with Crusaders and um I was looking at
the numbers as far the dollar figures
went and I was like
Wow uh and I was thinking on it cuz I
hadn't been given anything from
Crusaders at this point I was still just
w a training squad on that and then next
minute um Todd black came up to me and
said hey mate uh you got any uh anything
sorted as far as contracts and that go
for for next year and I was like oh no
not yet why is that he's like oh we'd
like to offer you a 2-year deal and I
was like oh yeah yeah here we go and uh
we hadn't talked about any sort of facts
and figures or anything like that this
was just a pretty sort of brief uh
informal passing conversation on the
side of the field here one day yeah yeah
shook hands I was like [__] yeah we're
on they they gave me the contract and
that and uh I looked at it and it was
like the be it was the minimum contract
uh for two years and uh I was looking at
my Southern Kings one and I was like wow
this is like over double you know
financially I was just
like I thought about it for a bit and I
was like I guess it's uh it's that
shortterm gain versus what I'd get if I
stayed here at Crusaders and did my
apprenticeship sort of thing under the
White crocketts and the and the Frank
spes you know um so yeah obviously I
made the made the decision to stay here
with Crusaders um but
uh yeah I I don't regret that at all now
looking back at how things have worked
out and everything so um yeah I don't
know where I'd be imagine yeah you'd be
scramming down for the
Box I'd say yeah I'd be I probably would
have had a few more Stakes put away if
if I'd gone on it over there man the old
seers love their meat so you'd be in the
bomb squad was it 40 minute
splits oh crazy that's sliding doors um
so what are your plans post bu have you
got much of an idea yeah post footy uh
the sort of the the dream aside from uh
footy and everything ever since I was a
kid was uh going farming so oh yeah um I
went to Lincoln Union and I did a dip
egg out there so oh did you uh I would
say not just a pretty face but it took
me a bit longer to get get me old piece
of paper than what it should have how
many years oh two and a half oh yeah for
a one year
yeah well juggling Pro proot it that's
understandable or did you f a fe you oh
you weren't even juggling I wasling by
by that
stage that was just uh that you are just
a pretty face there yeah that was just
having a good time and enjoying the uni
lifestyle but um
yeah uh so yeah I want to go farming
when I finished up with the footy um and
what field of farming I haven't really
decided as yet um de seems to be where
uh you're making the money at I guess
but it's also a lifestyle Choice as well
so um yeah like I saying I I don't
really know just yet but uh probably
need to start making some decisions on
that sooner rather than later though you
got time mate you got heaps of time few
more years here and then they head
overseas and that's what you look
forward to that you look forward to that
lifestyle of being in the farm and yeah
yeah I could I could never see myself uh
you know working any sort of a office
job or anything inside sort of thing
like that so um yeah I just love being
out in the you know open air and uh yeah
being a bit of a diesel jockey R you
know in the tractors and that sort of
thing and yeah bugging around with stock
and that sort of carry on so yeah that's
M you'll love it you'll absolutely love
it but anyway we've gone to our
Instagram for some questions plenty came
in a few that I'm pretty Keen to know
for True this one in particular
is it true that you wrestled case Muse
as a 14-year-old and beat him uh Yan
here case Muse I'm not sure if um I'm
not sure if I ever wrestled case Muse I
think that might have been Kyle hayon oh
Kyle hymon yeah did you wrestle him yeah
old uh Mike cron uh would always bring
in a few props in that uh to my old
wrestling club oh time the time and I
remember he bought on kle Heyman and uh
Jamie McIntosh oh true you would have
schooled whoer pretty
quick I remember old wapper cuz that was
before he had cracked into Super Rugby
and everything he was only jeez I think
he must have only been 20 old or
something and I was you know I think I
was 17 or 18 or something like that and
uh oh no I might have got the ages wrong
there anyway I might have been a bit
younger but any who I just remember old
Whopper he was he was massive he was
bigger than um Kyle Heyman yeah sh man
but yeah we had a we had a good we roll
around out on the Mets um so yeah you
did him you you did over kle hymon and
Whopper as a 14year old whatever age it
was um but yeah I just like they were
definitely uh well stronger than me and
bigger than me back then cuz when my
wrestling days I was I was only
wrestling in the under 96 kg C true and
I think both those guys at that point
were roughly around the the high 120s
you know like so um they had a few kilos
on me and probably could have probably
could have raged all me I suppose but um
yeah just had a bit of technique on my
side it's key okay but you must have
been strong as well cuz this one says
tell us about the time you beat New
Zealand strongman Levi in a carpool
competition when you were
17 uh again I'm not too sure that it was
that uh
Levi I did I
Mo yeah I remember the the M 10 man I I
don't think it was him but I did jump in
uh we were at a car show and uh I jumped
into the strongman competition and um
yeah I beat one of the strong men at the
at the carping comp true at 17 years old
yeah yeah so you were always naturally
really strong you must have been uh yeah
yeah I think I been relatively strong
through all my life yeah yeah far out
pull a car and beat a strong man at 17
did you ever think to go down that route
Strongman Competition I do love watching
a bit of the world strongest man but um
I think the the part that I most like
about all that is just the uh probably
their their diets and uh the calorie
intake um the fact they can just eat
what they want or try and smashing a
heap a Tucker and just worry about the
gym they don't have to worry about
cardio yeah yeah just get strong oh good
stuff okay well someone's asked a lot of
physical questions for you as a front
rower they want to know your best Bronco
bench Squat and deadlift so we'll start
with your best Bronco uh I've never been
very good in the Bronco Department um I
think my best uh even when I've been
really fit was uh I think it was 59 so
I've never cracked the sub five yeah it
was 509 was my best yeah you must have
ran a that recently too didn't you cuz
no one was much over that um I think
that was uh that was over the lockdown
period oh yeah yeah yeah got really fed
over
lockdown nothing else okay bench uh
bench was uh 183 oh that's getting heavy
very heavy yeah and squat uh 253 holy
bending
bars and deadli I've never actually done
a single rep of deadlift uh I've never
done a 1 RM but uh I've done a triple at
250 250 sheez yeah you are a strong
strong
human how good mate sounds like my
scores okay does he remind people about
the offload against France in
215 um what was this one you haven't
reminded me about it what was it
unbelievable out the back yeah we where
rled desle out the back door but um In
fairness I don't really remind anyone
about it but I get reminded about it a
little bit do you yeah oh man I have to
find that CP sounds like a glorious play
it was a we um set up a try yeah a tkb
oh yeah okay
yeah best best player of your career in
the in the loose obviously you probably
got scrummaging highlights
but um yeah Pro geez it probably would
be yeah right up there you got a nice
Runway against um Wales I know in that
game you weren't too Keen to play but
then you ended up loving it was that
about 25 M out you've sh a clean pair of
ha oh I thought it was closer to 40 m
but um you know it was probably roughly
something like that
yeah is that your favorite try or your
best try you've actually got what five
tries in the All Blacks and I know a lot
of props who have got none for a long
long time I think OE might be one of
those yeah um how have you scored so
many tries oh strike right probably just
um you know just being a seago you know
just hanging out till they get close to
the to the white line and then trying to
have a sniff n i I hate seeing props
that do that
um just a bit of luck really yeah um
yeah I've scored a couple of lucky ones
where I've been put on a Wei hole or
something like that yeah then there's
yeah then there's your just your
grafting uh we pick and goes bits and
pieces
um yeah I've oh couple of nice lines but
yeah right you have to have had to have
five
tries it's a good stat okay how often do
you get confused with Tom
Walsh unfortunately more often than I'd
like to admit
um throughout my whole career it's uh
I've always
been oh ow and franks ow and franks no
mate not me um but yeah the Tom Walsh
thing has come up uh quite a few times
as well yeah um yeah unfortunately you
do look like him though he I saw him at
the um Supermarket the other day and for
a second I genuinely thought it was you
from from about a I think I was at about
a 5:00 angle and M I genuinely thought
it was y see whenever I get mistaken for
anyone I'd just like to say to them you
know I'm way better looking than that
person but um
yeah did you ever
shotput I did do a little bit at high
school to be honest um yeah never went
any further than you know just going to
the into schools comps and that but yeah
he could imagine you two both competing
like absolute twins just going at it see
that's another great sport though you
know you don't have to worry about too
much cardio just get that power based gy
I walk to the to the circle and you're
away okay next one uh um tips for young
props to perfect their
craft oh I guess um the biggest tips I
could probably give you would be um sort
out your own your own setup first uh
even if that's just doing you know doing
your setup practicing your setup in the
mirror um getting all that right um I
guess the the biggest key um to help you
out where you're where you're sort of
learning and just uh developing yourself
would be uh big chest and straight back
you know cuz uh as soon as you start
bending your back uh you lose all your
power it doesn't me matter how strong
you are through your legs or whatever um
you can't you can't put that power
through if you're if you're you know
bending in the back and whatnot and so
yeah just keep your chest out and uh
back straight scrum coach career or
you're going to be wasted on the farm
coach in the coaching the cows out of
scrum no definitely not I couldn't see
myself coaching after footy to be fair
unless some uh you know maybe have have
a few little young Fells running around
or something and Coach a bit of Junior
footy or something like that but fair
enough okay what kind of preps do you
what kind of prep do you do on an
opposition key differences between
scrummaging a 6'4 prop and a 5 foot n
prop um to be honest
uh it all yeah I suppose that's
a yeah you've you've put it well in the
question uh it changes a lot in uh how
you're going to try and attack that tall
guy and their setup and everything
versus uh how the shorter gu is going to
set up and everything uh but at the same
time it's it's hard to kind of explain
because um if they both set up the same
way um
you're going to attack them the same way
if you know what I mean but um generally
speaking uh the taller guys and the
shorter guys will uh you know bring a
foot back at different stages or if they
move both feet to get themselves in the
right spot uh that's when you can apply
the pressure on binds and that sort of
thing or um trying to give a bit more of
a chase after the hit to cramp them up
so that they can't get into their long
strong positions
um yeah I guess uh there's a couple of
the key sort of ways to look at things
[__] there's a bit to down I know you're
just uh scraping the service surface not
trying to get too technical but yeah
exactly it's just you you kind of have
to look at a clip and go over someone
something like that with them if they
want to get really technical into things
like that but yeah so there's no real no
one's harder to scrummage with with
their height shorter guys aren't harder
to scrummage and taller guys it's just
how they set up basically yeah I
sometimes I prefer scrummaging the
shorter guys cuz uh I can get a longer
bind with them right you know right back
up onto their shorts and that rather
than just in the middle of the back with
a taller guy sort of thing so it's um
yeah both both have got uh pros and cons
for um yeah scrumming against them yeah
who's the hardest person to scrum
against that's another question here uh
honestly um I've kind of always felt
like my good mate neps nipp
he's uh he's been one of the one of the
best uh tight head scrummaging props
that I've sort of ever ever had to scrum
against so um yeah I'd have to say nees
what's he do so well good setup just so
strong he's got a huge thick chest um
which he knows how to use on top of a
loose head um yeah chest and shoulders
he just he uh squeezes it down on the
back of your neck and uh yeah he's he's
not trying
to he's not trying to collapse it like
some tight heads think they just need to
hit the ground sort of thing but he just
puts that pressure on you um to hold
hold you down and hold you in the spot
where he wants and uh he never never
gives you an opening to sort of tuck in
and slide underneath him or anything so
um he's just a a very very tough tight
head to scrum against and uh he's also
got a bit of power to back it up as well
and yeah mate f ating loving it loving
the scrum chat okay tell us a story of
when you got caught handing out candy to
young
girls can you tell me who's giving that
question my neighbor
maybe oh yeah so I was in a living in a
we subdivision um and my neighbor across
the road he was a good fell he worked
for Mars Bars yeah and he always used to
hook me up with a we stash of chocolate
and that from time to time and I just
walked over the road to pick up my week
collection from him
and um as I was walking back across the
road uh these two young girls were
riding past me on their scooters I don't
know how old they were maybe like 10 10
11 sort of thing and I just said hey
girls um do you guys want some chocolate
cuz he'd given me a stack of like I
don't know 10 slabs of chocolate sort of
thing you could have them the offseason
again yeah and they stopped and they
kind of looked at me like what are you
serious like and then one of them said
what do we have to do for it I was like
no like that shocked me actually when
she said what do we have to do for it I
was like no no no like do you just do
you just want some chocolate like oh
yeah okay so I gave them each a you know
a um block of chocolate each and just
walked inside and thought nothing more
of it and that was that and then later
on um I was on the community uh Facebook
page and it was blowing up they'd gone
home told their mom and whatever and
then the mom had posted on the Facebook
page there's some creep out there
handing out chocolate to young girls and
whatnot and everyone was like oh that's
SEO
whatever did they describe him they did
describe him actually they said um oh
late 20s which I was pumped with uh and
yeah no way that's how they described
you late
20s and uh anyways I just yeah I
privately messaged the mom and I told
her it was me and you know what had
happened the bit of the back story with
the guy across the road and everything
so um yeah she was all good about it and
then sort of uh posted back on the on
the page just you know put telling
everyone to put their knives away and
the pitchforks away like we're not going
for a hunt for some creep that's trying
to luring young girls but
yeah oh sure that's good yeah oh what a
y okay next one tell us your secret to
making the perfect bacon and egg pie oh
um I like to do a bacon and egg pie uh I
like to go big when I do it big big size
yeah so I'll have a a 30 tray of eggs
far out it's expensive there yeah
roughly 800 G of bacon MH um I like to
chop up some onion in there yeah and uh
plenty of cheese actually as well oh
yeah so I think cheese is the key yeah
um yeah I guess that's that's pretty
much the re oh a we splash of milk you
have to put a splash of milk in with say
there's a secret somewhere so I know you
beat the egg yeah I beat the egg I know
some people leave them you know so
you've got whole yolks and everything
but n that's not me with my bacon egg
pie I like to beat the egg with a bit of
milk yeah heap of bacon bit of onion
yeah and a lot of cheese and a lot of
cheese all right I like it yeah I've
heard different different methods you
know with uh spaghetti on the base and
that sort of thing but that's not you no
not me no the Joe Moody pie yeah okay I
like it I have to try it okay next one
what age did you start giving zero [__]
about what people
think
um oh that's probably been one of the
keys to my success to be fair not caring
what others have thought but um I don't
know I guess when I was younger I
suppose I did care a little bit um but
then it it was probably
uh I don't know those early 20s and I
just started thinking yeah no point yeah
exactly why why care and worry about
what other people are thinking as long
as you know whatever I'm doing is not
not harming others around me and I'm
enjoying myself it's you know yeah who
gives a [__] was it easy to do because I
think a lot of people try and do it but
not many people do but you you look like
you just give zero yeah that's yeah um I
think for me it was relatively easy uh
yeah maybe I'm a special breed or
something I'm not too sure cuz I know
like what you said uh for a lot of
people it can be easier said than done
um yeah for me personally um it just
sort of comes easily yeah right I love
it I love that part of you okay last one
best piece of advice for wood lead
listener
uh do what you love and
uh if you yeah it comes back to giving
zero [__] if it comes down to anyone
else what they think you should do and
it's not for you [__]
them M what a way to finish one of the
great podcasts M it's been awesome going
through um your journey um crazy story
how it's all happened and some of the
setbacks and um the whole the whole
overall Journey but it's awesome to see
you where you're at now I even got an
exclusive from you that next year this
could be your last year so that's I'm
going to shock the nation and shock a
few people around here but um really
appreciate you giving up your time out
you've been awesome to work with last
year and um looking forward to what's
ahead for you this year hopefully you do
if you do finish this year you go out in
style with what you deserve and um look
forward to seeing you at your farm in a
few years time sounds good mate thanks
for having me on you're
[Music]
lead what a l what an absolute
glad what a l what a l what a l an
absolute
[Music]
GL